(plane taking off)
- What's up believe nation?
It's Evan, happy weekend.
I am testing a new series
that I want your feedback on
and we'll see out it goes.
This is the official launch,
soft launch, test of the series.
The idea is to basically look at
different categories of books
to try to filter down to
some of the best books
from different topics to help you build
and grow your business.
And so to launch it,
I want to talk about the
top five marketing books.
I'm going to list off the books
and then we're going to
hear from the authors
about what's inside the books
to give you a little bit more context.
I hope you guys enjoy.
I'd love to know your thoughts
on this video.
Whether this series should continue
or not with other topics.
Leave it in the comments
below and let me know.
Alright so coming at number five,
is The Power of Broke by Daymond John.
(guitar music)
- This book is called The Power of Broke,
and when you open the book
the first thing you read is
"The power of broke is a mindset.
"It exist in all of us,
"whether we have money,
opportunities or advantages.
"Trouble is, most people
don't recognize the power
"for what it is.
"They leave it alone,
"or maybe they don't
even know it's there."
What is the power of broke?
What do you mean by that?
- That's that hunger.
That's that drive.
That's that instinct that nothing
is ever going to stop you.
Listen, I'm not sitting
there saying that to be broke
and not have those resources
to feed your family
and get great medical attention
is something we should celebrate.
I'm not saying that by far.
But I'm saying that,
if you're going to be in a situation
where you don't have the
things that you want in life
and you're hungry,
then that's the situation,
let's tap into it.
And the people that I see
utilize The Power of Broke,
more than anybody at
all, are the people that
when they reach a level of
success they still use it
and that's how they
maintain their success.
That hunger and drive.
And we grow up at a time
and age where it was,
you need money to make money,
you got to know somebody.
Well, you know, I mean look at me.
Look at half this room.
I grew up African
American, short, dyslexic,
got left back one time, almost
got left back a second time,
can't dribble a basketball, can't sing,
can't draw, didn't know anybody,
didn't go to college,
that didn't stop me at all, right?
I had a mother that really loved me dearly
and I had some like-minded
frugal partners and friends,
who would never let me stop
and I never let them stop,
and I had a will and a drive
and I still have all those same things.
I still rise and grind
every single morning.
You see me in a suit on TV
handing out millions of dollars.
Looking like another just
buttoned up executive.
But it wasn't always like that.
You see, I had a secret tool.
It was there for me when
I had absolutely nothing.
When I thought I was nothing.
Until it lead me to everything.
You may think it's your biggest weakness.
But if you wield it properly,
it will definitely be
the key to your success.
This is The Power of Broke.
- You tell me you couldn't be authentic,
or original, or come up with some concept.
No matter what you have,
there's enough to do it.
- Broke can break you or
give you immense energy.
If you're someone that refuses to lose,
it's going to give you
all the fuel you need
to continue to push further.
- The level of rejection,
and the height to which
we're trying to aspire to
at times feels so
insurmountable and crazy.
- The people who are in
a position to buy my book
where not my target audience,
and so it didn't register for them.
- One of my favorite sayings is,
"Try, fail, try again, fail better."
- Being without capital
is one of the greatest gifts you can have
if you're an entrepreneur.
- Capital isn't the most
important ingredient
for business any more.
It's now creativity and passion.
- And I want people to believe
that they can actually be
whatever they want to be.
Do whatever they want to do.
And really the sky's the limit.
You know, it's people.
(orchestral music)
- There will never be a perfect time
there will only be you
making time perfect.
(orchestral music)
- Coming in at number four is Hooked:
How to Build Habit-Forming
Products, by Nir Eyal.
(guitar music)
- My name is Nir Eyal and I'm the author
of Hooked: How to Build
Habit-Forming Products.
I wrote Hooked for two reasons.
First, I wrote it for the product makers,
the designers, the
innovators, the entrepreneurs.
People who are struggling
to build products
to help people live better lives.
This book provides a framework
to help them build the right thing sooner,
to use the deeper psychology
of why users do the things they do,
so that we can help
them live better lives.
The second reason I wrote Hooked
is that I'm concerned the world
is becoming a potentially
more addictive place.
Technology is not only
becoming more pervasive,
but also more persuasive.
And so, if we need to learn
how to live with these technologies,
how to put technology in its place,
we have to understand
the deeper psychology
driving why we use these
goods and services.
And so, by understanding
how these products change our behavior,
we can make sure that
we control our habits,
as opposed to our habits controlling us.
- Coming in at number three is
Go Pro: 7 Steps to Becoming A
Network Marketing Professional
by Eric Worre.
(guitar music)
- Go Pro:
7 Steps to Becoming A Network
Marketing Professional
We talk about the skills
that you need to develop
and a road map to start
developing those skills.
A lot of people are surprised to learn
that there's only seven skills
that you need to develop
in order to be a network
marketing professional.
Seven skills, not seven hundred.
These skills are all learnable,
they're all doable,
and they're all repeatable.
You can teach them others
but you need to know what they are,
how to develop them,
and how to practice and get better.
I want to help the people involved
in the network marketing profession.
I love the people
in the network marketing profession
more than any other group in the world,
because they're courageous,
they're entrepreneurial to their core,
they go against the grain.
This book can help you
to really kind of formalize
the skillsets
that you need to develop, number one,
that you need to teach, number two,
and you need to replicate, number three.
You may have heard some of
these concepts here and there,
but I haven't seen anywhere,
anywhere in network marketing,
where we put it all in one place.
The thing about this book
is it's an easy read.
It's 160 pages.
Pretty logically laid out.
We're going to be talking about
the principles of network marketing
and also the skillsets
involved in network marketing.
But when people pick this book up,
what I want them to do
is not just read it.
Because you can read it logically
kind of understand it in one read,
but I want them to underline it.
I want them to highlight it.
I want to go back with a fresh mind
on a regular basis
and say, "Okay let me take a look at
"how to find people to talk to
"about my network marketing business.
"Let me take a look at
how I'm going to present,
"or how I'm going to promote for events,
"or how I'm going to get people started,
"these different skillsets."
Right?
I want you to learn it so well
that you could teach it, okay?
Because when you can do that
then your organization is
going to really take off.
- Coming in at number two is
The Tipping Point:
How Little Things Can
Make A Big Difference by
Malcolm Gladwell.
(guitar music)
- A couple years ago, I was
covering the AIDS epidemic.
So I got very interested in
the internal dynamics of epidemics,
because their own, sort of weird logic.
And it just began to occur to me that
I didn't understand why,
when we talk about contagious things,
we confine our conversation
to viruses or to diseases,
because clearly--
- The phenomena of disease
could be attributed
to other places,
to other ideas.
- Yes, exactly.
Those same principles, I mean,
so many different things or other things,
ideas, trends, song lyrics,
are contagious in precisely the same way.
I mean, I talk in the book
about the word "yawn".
If I say the word "yawn" long
enough you will start yawning,
and people watching this
show will start yawning.
That's an incredibly contagious word.
And it's contagious in
precisely the same way as--
- Contagion meaning everybody catches it
or contagious--?
- Everyone's catching it and
it's spreading from one source everywhere.
The same thing is true for, I think,
for products or ideas or
behaviors, especially.
I talk in the book about all
kinds of contagious behaviors.
Well, the tipping point
is the word that comes
from the study of epidemics,
is the describe that
moment in the epidemic
when it explodes.
The moment of critical mass.
And if you look at every epidemic,
there is always that moment
when the curve suddenly
shoots up very sharply,
and dramatically.
And so understanding how you can get
to the tipping point is really this,
is the critical question.
The word-of-mouth epidemics
are something that
I spend a lot of time on in the book.
People use that phrase without
ever saying what they mean.
I hear it all the time.
So-and-so is great, what about--
And I had never read an explanation,
an actually attempt to pin down
what that phenomenon is.
If there is such a thing as word-of-mouth,
who starts it?
Who sustains it?
Who creates it?
So I decided--
- [Interviewer] Did somebody start it?
- Oh yeah, absolutely.
The whole first part of the
book is an attempt to say
"Alright, this personality is responsible
"for starting word-of-mouth."
This personality, and
I have profiles of each
of these kinds of people, is responsible
for spreading it.
This is the kind of person.
Because it comes directly from,
it's and idea borrowed
directly from disease.
From diseases.
If you look at disease epidemics,
they are started and spread
by a tiny, tiny group
of exceptional people.
That same idea, I think,
is a really powerful way of understanding
this previously amorphous
concept of word-of-mouth.
- And taking the number one spot is
Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook:
How to Tell Your Story
in a Noisy, Social World,
by Gary Vaynerchuk.
(guitar music)
- If you look at what's happening
in the current state of social,
there's too many people
trying to close on the first move, right?
Every piece of content is, buy my home,
buy my wine, buy my agency,
just too much selling, and so to me,
what I'm trying to
transition, organizations,
people, everybody really into is, listen
you've got to be come a media company.
And a media company writes articles,
writes articles, and then has an ad.
Writes articles, writes
articles and then has an ad.
And to me the thing that
has converted the best
for me, as salesman, remember
I'm not Mother Teresa,
I'm doing this stuff under
the context of business,
sure it matters for
education, world peace,
and all that,
but this is business for me,
the best thing that's worked for me is
give, give, give, and then ask.
And to me, I translate that into
Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook.
The book is about
the pieces of content
and auditing a hundred of them
and showing people how to do it,
but it ladders up to a thesis,
which is what I'm going
to talk about today
more than anything, which is
not theory but being a practitioner.
There's way too many people
watching this right now
that talk about being
a social media expert,
or knowing social media
but aren't in the depths,
in the deep sea of
knowing exactly what to do
on Facebook, Twitter,
Tumblr, Pinterest, Instagram,
to convert ORI.
I'm getting more on that kick.
Because I've come to realize
people like to do a lot of talking
and not as much executing.
- [Narrator] Bill asks,
"What's the best way
"for a right hook to seem like a jab?"
- Bill, Bill, Bill, Bill, Bill.
Am I happy with you,
because you've asked a question
that means so much to me
and is something that so many
of you
are
confused
by.
Bill, I really appreciate you
and I'm not trying to sting,
but it might feel a little like that.
(laughs)
Trying to make a right hook
feel like a jab
is what 99%
of sales people and businesses do
that end up failing.
It is in the clear honesty
and clear track
of when I want to do
something nice for you,
I just do it.
Allah this show.
I just want to take 15
to 20 minutes of my day
to share the God-given wisdom
and the work experience
and I want all of you to watch it,
and I want this (gestures)
in return.
Now, come 15 months from now,
18 months from now,
whether it's a book,
whether it's a seminar,
whether it's an event,
whether it's me selling rare toys,
who knows what it might be,
then I will clearly say,
"Buy this friggin' rare toy.
"It's 9.99.
"Buy it now."
But, up until that point
I will have very clear ...
They'll be no show,
where you're watching the show
and behind the scenes right now
there's subliminal music pumping,
"Buy the damn cat for 9.99."
There is none of that.
And so, there's a massive confusion
in the marketplace, Bill,
that people want to disguise the sale
and there is no disguise.
Authentically, all in, all of it.
All in.
Give when it's time to give.
On the flip side,
there's a crap load of Mother Teresa's
and think it's so nice and awesome
and if you're just good it's good.
No, you need to sell.
So when you sell, you say, "I'm selling.
"I am selling this
"and I feel comfortable."
When I put a link out
buy my book.
It's out, buy it.
If I've done anything for you, buy it.
So, the answer to the
question is very simple.
There is no version of that.
That is a losing mentality and execution
and I highly recommend that you take it
and you split it very hard apart
where the jabs are clear
and where the right hooks are clear.
- So those are the top five
marketing book suggestions
for entrepreneurs.
I'd love to know, what do you guys think?
This is the test of a new series.
Did you enjoy this?
Show we continue it?
Are there other categories
you want me to cover?
Your views, your engagement,
your loyalty to this series,
will determine whether
we continue it or not,
so let me know.
Leave it down in the comments below.
Thank you guys so much for your support.
I hope you enjoyed this video.
If there's a six, seven, eight, nine, 10
that you want to add to this
list that we missed out,
also share that down in the comments.
I believe in you.
Hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
(plane taking off)